cuando estabas aprendiendo a multiplicar
hace muchos muchos años seguramente te
encontraste con esta noción de que 1 por
x es igual a ese mismo x lo cual tiene
muchísimo sentido no o sea si tomamos
uno de esta cosa pues simplemente nos
queda esta cosa ahora si estamos en un
ambiente de aritmética y nos fijamos en
este número este número tiene una
propiedad muy importante y justo a esta
propiedad de que cualquier número por
este número es ese mismo número le
llamamos la propiedad de identidad de la
multiplicación ok propiedad
e
identidad
y ahora que estamos trabajando tanto con
las matrices pues nos podemos preguntar
si existe alguna matriz que cumpla con
esta propiedad o sea haber para ser más
claros vamos a preguntarnos si existe
una matriz i
tal que si la multiplicamos por alguna
otra matriz por ejemplo una matriz
nos quede exactamente la misma matriz
que hay donde esta multiplicación es la
multiplicación clásica entre dos
matrices y para tener esto de una forma
más concreta vamos a ver un ejemplo
digamos por ejemplo que tenemos que que
la matriz a es una matriz de 3 x 3
y que sus entradas son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y
9 y te recomiendo que le pongas una
pausa al vídeo y trates de encontrar
cómo tendría que ser esta matriz para
que se de esta ecuación
por ejemplo puedes empezar por pensar
qué dimensiones debería de tener esta
matriz pero bueno voy a pensar que ya le
pusiste pausa hiciste un montón de cosas
para tratar de encontrar esta matriz y
entonces pues vamos a empezar por copiar
esta matriz y ponerla por aquí y sabemos
que queremos multiplicar a esta matriz
por la matriz
y además que la multiplicación de estas
dos matrices va a ser exactamente igual
a la matriz
entonces vamos a multiplicar a la matriz
y por una matriz que tiene tres filas y
tres columnas y además lo que nos va a
quedar es una matriz que tiene tres
filas y tres columnas ahora para que la
multiplicación entre estas dos matrices
esté bien definida esta matriz tiene que
tener el mismo número de columnas que el
número de filas que tiene esta matriz
para poder hacer este vector producto
punto con este vector si no no podríamos
multiplicar estas dos matrices entonces
sabemos que el número de columnas de
esta matriz tiene que ser 3 por otro
lado también sabemos que el resultado de
estas dos multiplicaciones es una matriz
que tiene tres pilas y que además el
número de filas que tiene la matriz
resultante de la multiplicación es
determinado por el número de filas que
tiene esta matriz
entonces después para que esta matriz
tenga tres filas esta matriz tiene que
tener tres filas y bueno el número de
columnas que tiene esta matriz es
determinado por el número de columnas
que tiene esta matriz de aquí
aunque hay entonces para hacer esta
multiplicación y que nos quede esto
estos dos números tienen que ser
exactamente iguales y el número de filas
de esta matriz es igual al número de
filas del resultado y el número de
columnas de esta matriz es igual al
número de columnas del resultado ahora
que sabemos acerca de todo esto pues
sabemos cuánto tiene que valer el
resultado de estas multiplicaciones o
sea tiene que ser esta matriz 1 2
8 y 9 y además sabemos que este 1 de
aquí lo obtenemos multiplicando esta
fila de esta matriz por esta columna de
esta matriz ok para obtener este 1
tenemos que multiplicar 1 por alguna
cosa por aquí más este 4 por alguna otra
cosa por aquí más 7 por alguna otra cosa
y el resultado de esa multiplicación es
1 aunque ya estamos haciendo el producto
punto entre la primera fila de la matriz
y la primera columna de la matriz a y
eso nos da la entrada 11 de la matriz
del producto ahora también podemos
pensar en esto de una forma tal vez un
poquito ingenua y decir bueno si
queremos que el producto punto entre
estos dos vectores sea igual a 1 porque
no en ésta y la de aquí hacemos que el 1
se multiplique por un 1 y que el 4 y el
7 se multipliquen
y entonces a la hora de hacer el
producto punto entre esta fila y esta
columna para obtener esta entrada lo que
nos queda es uno por uno
uno por uno más cero por cuatro más cero
por siete y eso sí es igual a uno
entonces por lo menos para esta entrada
así funciona nuestra simple idea pero
pues tenemos que checar que funcione
para el resto de las entradas no
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa si hacemos
el producto punto entre esta columna
y esta fila
lo que vamos a obtener es esta entrada
cierto porque estamos en la primera fila
por la segunda columna entonces
obtenemos esta entrada y pues nos queda
2 por 1 2 + 0 por 5 + 0 por 8 o sea que
si nos queda 2 y lo mismo pasa con esta
última entrada de la primera fila o sea
nos queda 3 por 13 + 0 x 60 x 9 y eso sí
es simplemente el 3 que estábamos
buscando
pero bueno nuestro recorrido no termina
aquí ahora qué pasa con la segunda fila
de la matriz y pues la segunda fila de
la matriz y va a tener mucho que ver con
cuánto vale la segunda fila de la matriz
producto ahora vamos a ver que tenemos
que poner en esta fila ok
está chile producto punto con esta
columna lo que nos va a dar es
esta entrada y si te fijas esta entrada
es la entrada de en medio de esta
columna
entonces nos queremos deshacer de estos
dos valores y para hacer eso pues vamos
a multiplicar este vector por el vector
cero
a 0 y entonces nos queda 1 por 0 0 + 1
por 4 4 + 0 por 7 y entonces en total
nos queda 4 que es justo lo que
queríamos y funciona igual para el resto
de estas entradas no sé al multiplicar
esta fila por esta columna que es lo que
nos va a dar esta entrada lo que nos
queda es 2 x 0 0 + 1 por 5 5 + 0 por 8 y
entonces nos queda simplemente el 5 y
funciona exactamente igual para esta
entrada
bueno entonces tenemos una última fila
que tenemos que descifrar
esta fila ayuda a determinar qué valores
tomen estas entradas ok para obtener
esta entrada tenemos que hacer el
producto de esta fila por esta columna y
si lo que queremos es quedarnos con el 7
pues simplemente necesitamos poner 0 0 y
1 y entonces el producto punto de esta
fila por esta columna es 0 por 1 + 0 por
4 + 1 por 7 y termina siendo 7 y
fácilmente puedes ver que el producto de
esta fila por esta columna es
simplemente un 8 y el producto de esta
fila por esta columna es el 9 entonces
así de fácilmente hemos construido una
matriz que tenga esta propiedad de
identidad que si la multiplicamos por
esta matriz a nos queda exactamente la
matriz
ahora en realidad aquí en lugar de la
matriz a pude haber puesto a cualquier
otra matriz y hubiéramos obtenido el
mismo resultado ósea en serio si ponemos
aquí cualquier matriz y la multiplicamos
por esta matriz nos queda esa matriz que
pusimos aquí originalmente entonces la
matriz identidad de 3 por 3 es la matriz
0 1 0 0 0 1
y vas a ver cuando construyan más
matrices de identidad de distintas
dimensiones que todas tienen exactamente
la misma estructura
por ejemplo la matriz identidad pero de
4x4 la matriz 1 0 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 1 0 0
0 0 1
y por ejemplo la matriz identidad de 2 x
es simplemente 1001 aunque hay todas
tienen exactamente la misma estructura
que es simplemente tomar una matriz
cuadrada de las dimensiones correctas
poner puros unos en la diagonal y puros
ceros en todas las demás entradas y que
es lo importante y bonito acerca de las
matrices identidad pues es esta
propiedad que si las multiplicamos por
alguna otra matriz nos queda esa otra
matriz bueno ya ahora te voy a proponer
que hagas algo cuando termines este
vídeo y es averiguar qué pasa cuando
estamos multiplicando a por la matriz y
pero en este orden hemos visto en
algunos vídeos que el orden en el que
multiplicamos las matrices si importa
entonces la pregunta es qué pasa con
esta multiplicación será igual a la
matriz